[Musique]
ne nous y trompons pas des lois
régissent le désordre apparent de ses
pieds qu'il soit intelligent ou lourdaud
nighy faut ruser alerte ou fatigué il ne
suffit pas en effet de marché pour être
un piéton digne de ce nom
voyez monsieur dupont il était pas de
ses piétons qui se franchiser paris
lorsqu'il attendait son autobus on le
voyait souvent négligé le trottoir
il nourrissait pas par choix évident
pour les autobus en marche à la montée
comme à la descente
ceci ne l'avait d'ailleurs pas empêché
le lendemain de ce livre est un slalom
très inconsidérés au milieu des voitures
pour traverser la petite place de la
concorde
et une nuits que monsieur dupont avait
encore une fois négliger le trottoir et
s'il n'est pas mort cette nuit là il est
allé néanmoins rejoindre les 28 milles
qui étant blessés chaque année
un conseil pour être prudent n'attendez
pas un accident
il serait peut-être trop tard
[Musique]